bonjour
Félicitations merci beaucoup
enchanté
un mélange de comme pourquoi nous on est
content qu'est-ce qu'on fait
il faut commander peut-être commander un
peu plus de nourriture pour cette
semaine
[Musique]
comment vous l'avez reçu vous
ben c'est un grand honneur mais aussi
une grande surprise on est on est ravis
mais en même temps très étonné là on est
dans une liste avec tous nos idoles on
est on est un peu chamboulé là par tout
ça mais soyez que le 34 au Québec ce qui
est une bonne nouvelle pour la
restauration du Québec mais vous les
coiffer tous
il doit avoir quelque chose que vous
faites de magie
vous allez pas m'avoir avec cette
question là mais en fait et en fait
c'est les listes une année on va être
premier l'année d'après on va être 15e
de la façon qu'on travaille qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de plus je sais pas je pense
pas qu'on fait rien de plus je pense
qu'on en fait peut-être moins voilà
c'est intéressant je vais vous citer
commentaire du l'éditeur
qui a décerné il dit
la cuisine de mon lapin est très
discipliné le service est impeccable
mais c'est tout sauf prétentieux on
injecte une dose de plaisir dans la
cuisine gastronomique c'est la voie du
futur une espèce de simplicité dans les
choses qui sont très bien faites ça se
peut ça on a juste nous on opère notre
restaurant comme un endroit où on veut
aller manger nous donc c'est vrai que
c'est sans prétention puis c'est vrai
que là de se faire reconnaître comme ça
c'est peut-être un peu la voix de de
l'actuel désir des gens on veut
continuer à être un resto de quartier on
veut continuer à accueillir les gens qui
habitent dans le coin et puis vous
voulez rester accessible il oublie pas
être projeté sur une autre planète là on
se dit que si on était nommé dans cette
position là dans cette liste c'est pour
que c'est pour qui qu'on est vraiment on
va pas il y a pas de Naples au
restaurant Les notre sommelier il est
pas en complet dans le sens notre la
façon qu'on est c'est la façon qui était
reconnue puis je crois que finalement ça
ça l'encourage ça félicite une façon un
peu différente de faire de la
restauration de façon un petit peu moins
traditionnelle à côté de ce qui était on
parle souvent de gastronomie c'est quoi
la gastronomie la gastronomie elle a été
souvent mis dans une certaine case il y
a peut-être un certain changement de
casse qui se passe et en ce moment parce
qu'on rentre pas dans le moule de ce que
quelqu'un pourrait imaginer
[Musique]
gastronomique
vous êtes dans la simplicité ça fait
partie de votre charme c'est ce que
quelqu'un qui vient souvent ici me
disait en même temps il doit avoir un
respect infini pour les produits pour le
pour les choses faites à la perfection
quand même à la perfection on y arrivera
jamais donc faut pas nous mettre ces
mots-là s'il vous plaît oui bien sûr on
est dans le produit on est dans le
respect et avec nos humains qui
travaillent ici et avec les fournisseurs
avec qui on travaille tout seul les vins
concerts ça fait partie de notre de
notre identité
évidemment pas un restaurant pour gagner
des prix sinon ça paraît puis je trouve
que ça se transparaît dans l'ambiance
dans la nourriture mais nous on est
ouvert un restaurant avec trois de nos
meilleurs amis vraiment
c'est un rêve de toute ma vie d'ouvrir
de d'ouvrir notre propre restaurant
avoir une reconnaissance pour quelque
chose qui est très personnel à nous on
cuisine pas très différent que si on
voyait inviter à la maison on sort les
mêmes vins que si on va s'en servir à la
maison c'est très cool d'être reconnu
pour quelque chose qui est vrai c'est
nous c'est très nous le restaurant
pandémie on a beaucoup beaucoup parlé de
restauration pendant la pandémie des
difficultés des restaurateurs vous vous
êtes vous avez fait du judo avec ça un
peu vous avez vendu du poulet frit je
crois pour emporter là vous êtes dans
une autre comment se porte la
restauration bon vous ça va bien mais en
général il y a eu des gros changements
dans la façon que les restaurants sont
opérés que donne la place
différents types de restaurants
s'exprimés des restaurants qui vont être
reconnus qui sont des opérations
beaucoup plus simple beaucoup moins
pesante administrativement côté
personnel côté loyer côté etc ce qui
donne la place à de la créativité puis
des talents que peut-être aurait été
étouffé dans des grandes structures de
se développer de s'épanouir puis je
trouve que la pandémie est vraiment aidé
que mercredi c'est incroyable le genre
de Silver Lining on dit en anglais les
choses qui ont émergé puis justement
cette quête d'équilibre que les gros les
petits recherches on les voit les heures
d'ouverture qui sont modifiées les
employés qui sont vraiment traités avec
beaucoup de respect c'est vraiment vers
ça qu'on s'en va c'est fantastique le
personnel ça va vous arrivez à trouver
on est on n'est pas là sans notre équipe
notre équipe est magnifique et
sincèrement sans eux se restant en
lestérien donc ouais non ça va bien
quoi ce soir
la semaine dernière puis là c'est ça
pour de bon là asperges au mort c'est
donc je vous souhaite de rester
vous-même mais il va avoir le téléphone
va sonner encore plus ça sonne pas mal
est-ce que c'est possible de venir
manger quelqu'un qui écoute là ce soir
vous n'êtes pas parce qu'on en est Jobé
c'est comme si moi un an là c'est sûr
que on est petit donc on va essayer de
dire oui le plus possible en espérant
que personne nous en veulent si c'est
plein voilà merci félicitations merci
beaucoup merci merci